Okay,
we are live.
Hi.
I think I'm going to start today by
writing a quick article because I have
something on my mind to write about and
uh I figured I'd do it on stream
and then I have a meeting in an hour and
a half. So, I think I can probably write
article in that time and uh maybe get
started on a little bit of drone stuff.
After my meeting, I'll be working on
drone stuff for most of the rest of the
day. Hey, Linky, welcome
release all of these, I guess. Did I?
Oh, yeah. I guess I didn't really
release this. Okay.
Then this ended up just being the tweet.
Yeah, that's fine. Uh, let's do new
just like quick free form article.
Can we get Yaxine to stream dev? You can
try to. He's definitely working on some
stuff. He sent me some cool things.
I don't know what he's talking about. Uh
yeah, I have no idea.
I'm like a little bit scattered with
stuff I do. He's like very very
scattered with the type of stuff he
does, you know?
in new to thread.
Yes.
Yeah. So, like the nan issue, it's
numerical instability most of the time.
It's not like, oh, it can't work with
sparse rewards or something like that.
I don't think it should be. The thing
that's difficult is the fact that like
it's pretty hard to express these ops on
a touring machine. That's it.
I'm curious why did you decide to do a
PhD?
Uh if I gotten a full-time offer, I
would have stayed.
Like you uh
it was pretty dang hard to even like
even being a publishing researcher as an
undergrad.
the positions were almost exclusively
for PhDs.
I mean, and not only that, right, like I
also I was pretty stubborn about what I
wanted to work on as well. Like I didn't
kind of just want to work on anything.
I was pretty like I had my mind set
pretty pretty hard on neural MMO and
multi- aent and all this stuff. It would
have probably
it would have had to have been like a
lab that wanted to bet on an undergrad
to work on like this crazy ambitious
project that really could probably only
have been done in academia. And I guess
the proof of that, right, is I worked on
neural MMO and I didn't expect to do it
for my entire PhD because I expected,
you know, one of the big labs to circle
back and eventually do it way bigger and
way better and they just never did.
So I was really the only one pushing
like despite Starcraft and Dota and all
these things, none of the labs did like
a compelling thousand agent learning
problem or like you know economies and
trade and stuff or any of the things
that we did with neural MMO Oh,
This is underrated to be able to write
quality stuff,
right in one go. It depends on how I'm
feeling, man.
I don't consider this super high
quality.
curious about your thoughts on scaling
up nets.
The Dota works with one layer, Kevin.
The one layer LSTM you scale with
And uh we do actually see this
we see this on some of our problems but
it's it's a factor of problem
complexity.
So simple problems don't benefit from
more than 128 width.
Something like neural MMO so far we've
gotten it up to 512 doesn't really get
all that much more from 1024
is massively massively complicated. It's
up to 4096.
I think that people have this bias in
their head that because LMs are big,
then everything needs to be big. But
it's just not true. RL's just a data
sponge. You don't need that big of
networks
to solve things.
Now I will say if you have a supervised
objective in your RL then that can scale
which is a thing I wanted to look at
with you right so I don't think that you
necessarily need to scale the policy
massively but if you have some
supervised objective like a world model
or a contrastive objective or whatever
that it seems can scale and there's good
evidence
dropping by say the goat works
incredibly inspiring. Keep on
keep on keeping on. Thank you very much.
If you want to get involved with this
stuff, I mean, we literally have brand
new programmers who have spun up and are
now actively contributing to our
research
public in the Discord.
You read Simba
and Bro, I heard of Simba. Not Bro,
I'm not going to take too much of uh
this bias.
I'll have to look at this.
And you know the other thing that's just
really screwy, Kevin,
I can look at this. Here's the thing
that just sucks. Okay,
I treat publications as false by default
now in RL.
You know, like when I read a new
publication, I assume it's wrong by
default because that's literally been a
better prior than anything else. you've
replicated it. Does it work more
broadly?
Does there's a difference between
replicating the exact thing and it
actually being general, right?
Write it in my own M. Okay. See, that is
useful information.
I don't want to get too super
sidetracked by this now because I'll get
out of like a writing flow, but um I
will take a look at this. If you're
around later today as well, we can take
a look at this together. I will be more
than happy to uh to do that.
If you try it on Puffer M, that's like
25 data points. And if it works on
neural MMO 3 or even if it works on
mazes, mazes is like a fast training
environment that replicates like the
transfers really well then uh that will
be much stronger evidence.
applied BS
and I I don't know what applied to BS is
in the Discord when I gain a little more
experience. Yeah, there are literally we
have undergrads who are doing some of
the best work right now in Puffer Live.
There's no bias on experience level.
Like
the best time to just like start doing
stuff and learning things is now. You're
going to learn stuff way faster in here
as well.
We've had dozens of people spin up in
this and there's really no better way to
learn.
Like if you have any sort of programming
background, right? I can guarantee you
you're going to make be able to make one
of these environments and like get RL
working on it quite quickly and learn a
lot in the process. Even like a simple
arcade environment, something like a
breakout or a Pong like 2048, right? All
of these are like projects that are a
few hundred lines of code you can kind
of just knock out very quickly. Uh
chances are it's going to be a very
unfamiliar style, but like you will
learn a lot very very quickly. And
frankly, when I was in undergrad, I wish
somebody had just showed me this type of
stuff because it would have saved me a
lot of time.
So, a lot of the stuff that I've set up
around Puffer is like specifically
designed to get new people into this
stuff ASAP cuz like it's not that
complicated. There's not like a huge
amount of material that you need to know
to do this stuff. Well, you kind of just
have to be open to thinking about
problems differently from what you're
used to.
based in pure C. The environments are in
pure C. Only the environments. All the
training code is going to be like
familiar PyTorch and stuff. And believe
me, you're going to prefer the C because
there are just way fewer things that you
have to deal with at all. It's really
basic C. It's like the stuff that you
saw in literally your first systems
course ever. Um, if you're an undergrad,
like your literal first systems
like here, just take a quick look at it.
Like
if you just go to our code
read like snake or something, right?
D fan. It's all good. Okay, solid.
Usually that's the hard cell for AI
people because like this is snake. This
is like this really cool multi- aent
snake end like 300 lines and it's really
really simple code. Like this is not
anything that looks scary, right? And
this actually scales like it doesn't
really get much harder than this as you
build uh fancier environments.
random side note. Your old write up
about Arch Linux convinced me to set up
my laptop with Ri3. Oh jeez. Ah, you got
the blunder years stuff from that was I
wrote that in high school, man.
Oh jeez. It's not bad. Okay, it's good
for learning. I will say it's really
good for learning. I used Arch for like
most of undergrad and it's really good
for learning. Um
I think like honestly yeah you know what
keep doing that. It's when you're new to
all this stuff it will help you learn
just a lot of basic technical things.
Eventually, you get to the point where
it's like, look, I don't want to fight
with my audio drivers for three hours
and like be on the Arch Wiki to just
make my audio drivers work. I don't want
rolling updates to just randomly brick
my machine. Um, but it's good for
learning.
What I use now is three. Yeah. And it's
a pain because you have to set up three
computers like that, right? So, unless
you really have good scripts for
everything, but even then like they're
going to be hardware differences. I
typically just run like vanilla Abuntu.
Now, this machine's on Windows because
it's old, but like I run vanilla Abuntu
and then I have like a really minimal
Neoim config.
I actually, you know what? I recently I
tried to set up um I tried to set up i3
on my laptop, my new laptop, and I don't
even think it was i3 specifically, but
like there were just so many jank Linux
things with the hardware that it just
totally wasn't worth trying to customize
crap because like you don't know if you
broke stuff with your customizations or
it's just Linux being jank on laptops.
It's a total pain.
Honestly, best setup that I have these
days is just get a nice desktop.
Get a nice desktop. Stick like a vanilla
Abuntu on it
and then whatever editor of choice. I
got Neo Vim for um my stuff. Now, it's
got a total of two plugins. You don't
need to go crazy ricing everything.
Mostly a waste of time.
But uh I do actually,
at least for me, I like the like minimal
uh the minimalistic setup over the
really heavy tools. I still end up
fighting stuff, fighting stuff every so
often, but it's a lot easier for me to
fix my problems like this.
I actually some of that content is kind
of it's not good for learning, but it's
kind of informative.
Literally like I mean this is literally
me from high school, right? Um,
you can kind of see the level of stuff
where like
like what even is this, right?
No.
Uh, are we good?
I think the internet just blipped.
We should be okay.
Yeah. Okay.
It's just the internet blipping. I have
a really scuff setup here.
I'm in California on this super old
desktop. I haven't like figured out with
the internet. It does just blip every so
often.
the main facility. I'm going to end up
having it with two back like with an
extra backup line switch over, but done
that There.
Where's the epic wait room
in Maryland?
I have um I have setups everywhere, like
basic setups. the only really nice ones
in Maryland. Here in California, I just
have I've got a rack and a platform and
that's about it.
It sucks though. I've got a I've got a
shoulder injury and a knee injury. Knee
injury is getting better. So, I've been
able to run a little bit, but I have not
I'm not even try to squat yet. I can
deadlift. Uh, I've been I just started
benching a little bit again a few days
ago, but I'm I have to be super careful
with it. So, I'm just benching like
nothing like a plate for 20 reps or
whatever instead of 210 for 10, which is
what I was doing before
down literally 100 pounds.
It'll come back quick. I'm just being
careful because I really don't want to
reinjure it.
in Discord. Thanks for helping. Yeah,
thank you.
Focus on hurts my ego. Yeah.
right, let me take a quick read through
this and make sure it's not that crazy
rambly.
as I'm new here. Can you give me a
little context on what you're doing
here? Well, at the moment, I'm just
writing a quick article on uh some
thoughts on some reinforcement learning
stuff that I'm uh doing. In a few
minutes, as soon as I read through this
and post this, I'm going to start
working on
uh the drone swarming and drone racing
simulations that I've been work I've
been uh developing.
And we're going to see if we can get
capable swarming and racing policies
running like a few minutes with uh very
streamlined code.
The context for the stream in general is
I do reinforcement learning research
full-time. Sometimes I write about it.
Uh I release all this stuff open source
and I stream my whole process.
We've also got um a whole community
around this stuff. It's also helping
working on the reinforcement learning.
Um heck, most of the code at this point
is from contributors
live stream around the project.
Yeah, this is fine. This is just like a
quick stream of conscious article.
Let me go generate um some thumbnail for
it real quick.
Well, that's freaking horrifying. Look
at this. One hand, two hands.
Okay.
Yeah, let's not do that. Uh,
is there anything else I could use for
this?
Oh, yeah. I'm going to literally, this
will be funny.
Here, I'm going to go grab one of my
training graphs where the thing just
crashes.
make
This
automatically saved to the screenshots
fold.
The heck?
That's annoying. Where the heck is that?
H This is why I uh
this
Linux on this
Oh, it's a new folder that just made for
no reason. Well,
aspect ratio fixed.
This may be
All right.
I've got a little bit of time. Let's
start on the drone stuff and I will um
I'll continue on the drone stuff after.
I got one meeting in like half an hour
and afterwards we'll do drone stuff the
whole rest of the day I believe. Maybe
some other things. It depends how
quickly we uh we solve our problems
there. There anything I missed on here?
That's not going to a lot of stuff but
I'll have to look at it.
right. Well, it looks like we got lots
of questions, but our other contributors
are handling them. So, good. More time
for drones.
So, let me see if I can remember
if I can remember. What the heck?
I was trying to get this thing to work
with the new physics, I believe.
And I could get it to work with swarming
but not racing if I recall.
And it looked Yes. So it was it looked
like it was some weird reward bug and
then I randomly had to leave for um
impromptu meeting. That's what happened.
Okay, so let's see what the uh the
current task setup looks like.
So I we were trying to get it to train
on racing and yeah, I remember. So, this
Perf and score, this is good according
to the reward model, but it's not
actually going through any of the rings.
Uh,
there's a bit of trouble where it was
kind of a pain to get this stuff to
render.
I said I was going to do, but I didn't
because more meetings. Um,
but at least we do know based on this,
we do know that the uh the score is
good. So, there's a mismatch between
what the agent thinks that it's training
on or the agent says that it's uh
there's a mismatch between what we think
we're telling the agent to do, what the
agent is actually being told to do.
That's the way to interpret that because
the metric that it's optimizing is doing
well, but the metrics we care about is
not doing well. So there's a gap between
what we're optimizing and what we care
about.
I think that's the correct
interpretation of this.
Now it does occur to me as well that
this score function
the score function just is not going to
be able to even be very good, is it?
How can I get into RL physically? I have
skills 3D animation, Python and AI
generated with a bachelor's in physics.
Well, physics is definitely useful
um because there are all sorts of areas
where we're trying to figure out how to
like build out applications of this
stuff that require domain expertise in
other areas. For instance, to give you
an idea, uh the original math for the
drone simulator I'm working on now,
right? Okay, the original sim as well uh
was done by Finn and Sam who are in the
Discord and who are now working with us
to get this onto a real drone, right?
Because they were able to like they were
able to come up with a nice clean
formulation of the simple physics and
they were able to get it into a sim.
I helped them quite a bit on the RL
side,
right?
But like just having the experience in
another area often means that you can
come up with good applications and see
areas where oh yeah I could build a sim
for that
Let me see what happens if we do this.
So, I'm just going to swap it to like
the sparse reward, which is do you did
you pass a ring or not?
This should be quite hard to learn.
Uh, and if this works, then
we'll basically know that it's a a
reward formulation problem. What did I
mess up?
Sometimes when you edit stuff over SS
messes with the top of the file for some
dumb reason
adds a dumb character.
And I was spend Spencer some work as
well. I forgot I owed Spencer of racing
work today. That's the other thing we
got to do is the GPU drives sim
though.
But we'll message him after.
Well, it's passing. It's better, but
it's I think it's not passing.
Yeah. Multiple rings yet, right?
and know I remember this. This was it
like getting stuck only being able to do
one ring,
which is still better than what it was
doing before. So that's right.
I did make the rings farther apart. So,
if it doesn't have the um the sparse
reward, that could screw it up, right?
Want to make sure that the uh the
reward's what I think it is
check ring. Yeah. So it is getting the
check ring reward which is sparse.
I'm pretty sure I tried the uh the
sparse reward small map thing though and
I think it didn't work. We'll try it
again just to make sure I'm
not misremembering. Right.
It's interesting to me that we have a
reward that in my mind doesn't make a
ton of sense.
but we know it worked on the other the
other version.
One one last thing.
One other thing I modified, right?
Like this max rings 10.
Let's actually do one.
We should actually be able to confirm
just based on this.
Now we're as close as possible to the
original setting. So something's totally
broken if it doesn't work on this.
cuz you never know, right? I don't think
I'm doing collision checks between the
drones for the racing task, but I could
accidentally be doing collision checks
and then the rings are just like too
small, right? There like lots of things
I could be messing up technically.
Okay.
Well,
There you go.
A little better. See if it keeps
training.
whether this is the result that we want
or not. Uh and and unstable.
If it was the targets or if it was the
uh the number of drones.
File contains no section.
So, if this doesn't train, then it means
that there've got to be like collision
checks enabled that I'm not aware of.
Okay. So, it's the rings somehow.
How does that make sense? It's the
number of rings.
Maybe not. Maybe this is the same. The
other one is
I grabbed torque, right?
If we just get it working local.
I can't debug this blind. Like too
fiddly.
Usually I can.
It's never optimal.
Okay. Hopefully we can actually get the
thing to run.
All these packaging problems. Yeah. See
all these packaging problems? All these
just go away if you run stuff on Linux
and use our container.
So like
this is not even a puffer lib problem.
This is just a Python is stupid and dumb
problem and like it's really annoying to
do. Uh you basically just need a docker
for any non-trivial package because of
what a mess the Python build system is.
And heck, literally setup tools just has
breaking changes constantly. Look at the
number of versions they ship. And many
of them have breaking changes, right?
They shipped like this many major
versions.
I use dev containers for a bit as well.
Um,
it native Linux is better. I just
haven't had time to set it up on this.
Okay, cool. So, here are drones.
Now, we will actually be able to eval
and tell what the heck is going on.
train this. I got a meeting in a few,
but I'm going to at least get one policy
that we can try. What's happening
people? Working on a drone sim training.
So basically we have we have independent
uh implementations in which
we can get all of these drones to race
through the rings. We can get them to
form uh swarms and formations and stuff.
And I want to get the same neural net to
be able to do everything. So like one
sim the drones can do everything.
That's what we have to do now.
These are just random right here. So,
I'm training this neural net over here.
Training this policy. Uh, it's buggy.
It's not a good score, but this is at
least going to give us a starter point
to try to figure out what's going on.
Still fun to look at.
We should definitely get like a better
drone model as well.
Technically, I could load the puffer
fish in, fly the puffer around.
How's the quick article doing from this
morning?
Oh, reasonably well,
huh?
Not bad at all so far for like a just a
super quick article.
finally have our e-loop uh eval loop
back.
Okay, so for some reason,
right, this is what these guys do.
Oh, that doesn't even look bad. What?
Wait, this doesn't look bad at all.
So, have I just been being stupid this
whole time? Like the
Are my metrics just wrong? Like these
don't look that bad.
Okay, well that's actually encouraging.
It's not just super cursed.
Well, we will continue this later today.
Uh, the things planned for later are the
drone environment and also I've got I've
got this driving simulator to debug with
Spencer to take a look at the policies
there. Uh, I may do that on stream for
fun. We will see. For the folks
watching, thanks for tuning in for the
morning session.
Uh, if you are new around here,
it's all free open source work.
Check it out on puffer.ai.
If you want to help me out for free,
start the GitHub. Want to get involved
with dev discord. And if you want more
RL content, including a bunch of
articles for beginners and how to learn
and get into the space, follow me on X.
Thank you and uh back soon.